-You guys, if you watch
this show at all,
you know that I love
"Better Call Saul."
And if you watch
"Better Call Saul,"
You know that
Rhea Seehorn's portrayal
of Kim Wexler deserves
100 Emmys,
and I'm very happy to say
please welcome back to the show,
Emmy nominated ratio
Rhea Seehorn, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back to the show, Rhea.
Thank you.
-I'm so happy to have you.
-Emmy-nominated
Seth Meyers Show.
-Thank you, we both had
a very nice day last week.
We both got very nice news.
I was so genuinely happy to hear
that you got a long overdue
Emmy nomination.
Where were you --
-Did you guys see that tweet
he sent that morning?
Seth, you said that you were
more happy mine,
almost more happy
for mine nomination.
-Yes, I didn't lie.
I said I was almost
as happy, yeah.
It would be weird
if you said --
-Yeah, I think that I'm
just not a good enough
actor to pull it off.
Like, awards mean
nothing to me.
-I know.
-But my friend, Rhea.
But this is very exciting.
You were --
I read -- I read an article
about that you were overseas.
You were on vacation
when you got the news.
-Yes, I was in London
for the first time.
It was amazing, with my fiancee.
-I feel like the last three
years or so there's been like
talk of like
wouldn't it be great if.
So you probably had
some expectation the last
three years that you've had
to deal with some like
disappointment, right?
-Yeah.
-I mean, like, it's hard.
I mean, I think you're not
supposed to care,
but at the same time
you're sort of an ass
if you don't care at all.
-Yeah.
-Somebody saying nice
things like that, so...
And then of course you
and critics and amazing fans
have been lovely to me and
saying that they wanted me
to be nominated, so yeah,
I would sit there holding
my fiancee's hand and the
announcements would come out.
We'll be like, "Alright,
let's make oatmeal."
Moving on, and this year
we were -- I guess it was around
4:30 London time so I fully
opted for day drinking.
-Okay, got you.
Very smart.
You know I approve.
-Right.
I was at the -- it's called the
American Bar at the Savoy Hotel.
-That's really
cool that you went to London
and went to the American bar.
-I know.
Okay, by the way --
-Did you go to McDonald's
while you were there?
You've got to go
to the McDonald's.
-No, but... [ Laughs ]
There are patriotic things.
I'm not exactly sure
why they call it that.
It just like -- it was in my
little lonely planet guide.
-Okay, got you.
-Anyway, sorry.
Yeah, I like the books.
But we went and Jennifer Bryan,
our costume designer
from "Better Call Saul"
was there.
And I was like, "I'm putting
my phone away,
I'm just going to forget it."
And then my fiancee
squeezed my hand.
He was like I have
business deal,
and he's looking at something,
and then he said
"Babe, you just got it.
-That's so exciting.
-And then the whole bar knew,
and I didn't know
they knew who I was, and then
they brought champagne over
and clapped for me.
-Oh, see, if you were at
the British bar,
they would have had no idea.
[ Laughter ]
You were smart.
You played it right.
-They actually watch "Saul"
a lot over there.
-I bet.
-People watch me a lot.
-I mean, look, I think "Saul"
crosses all cultures.
It's a perfect show.
That's -- there's no reason --
-Thank you.
-I would imagine that the --
the rest of the day is then just
sort of a perfect day, right?
Because for me it -- it's that
thing of, like,
I don't know if you have that,
like a wave of just
relief of like, "Oh, I don't
have to, like,
think about this anymore."
-Yes.
-Like, whether or not
this will happen.
-But also I don't have to spend
the day pretending
that it doesn't matter.
Isn't that what you normally
have to do?
'Cause all day long people
are like, you have to answer
people's texts saying like,
"Oh, my God, this is awful.
You were snubbed."
It's just like, you know.
-Yeah.
I'd like -- right.
-"I'm totally fine."
-In another world I'm saying
it my wife, like,
"Look, it doesn't matter, we
have three healthy kids,"
where I barely care about that.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
Right. Today you get to be
honest about your priorities.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm like, "Look, I'm glad
they're healthy!"
-"But I got an --"
-"But I am an Emmy nominee."
-Exactly.
-I actually -- it was very sweet
because I -- I had gone out
for like -- I had gone
for a run, and I came home
and my wife had made --
the oldest son was holding a
sign saying "congratulations."
-Aw.
-Which was really sweet,
and then, they -- my kids were
like excited, and then he --
the six-year-old turned to give
me a hug, and just whacked
the four-year-old the in back
of the head with the sign.
And it was -- it was that --
it really was a very sweet,
grounding moment,
because in that moment
I was like, "Oh, I'm actually --
I feel worse that my
four-year-old got, like,
T-boned by this sign..."
-Right.
-"...than I feel good
that I got a nomination."
-Yeah, you have to switch
priorities, I like it.
-Um, and then --
-But also you were day drinking.
-Yeah, I was day drinking, too.
Even though it was --
the time difference was,
it was way too early.
-Totally fine.
Totally fine.
-You -- I want to stress,
if anybody's watching this
and worried about spoilers.
I don't want anything
spoiled for me,
I don't want to spoil the show
for anyone else.
And we are in a weird time right
now where we're having
an interview before tonight's
episode airs,
but when this airs,
that will have happened.
-Okay.
-So this is a weird, like,
we're in like a temporal,
like, doughnut hole.
-Oh.
-Yeah, so, it's a cool --
but -- so don't give
anything away.
But I know, because
it's been announced
that Carol Burnett...
-Yes.
-...is going to be in one
of the upcoming episodes.
-Have you met her?
-I have met her one time.
And it is like --
-She's amazing.
-It's amazing.
Super sharp, super funny.
-Yup.
-And the most important thing,
and I don't know if you feel
this way about when you
meet people you look up to,
super nice.
-Incredibly nice, yeah.
She's one of those people
where -- I mean, to me,
obviously she's a legend to lots
of people, she's a hero to me,
and just an icon and someone
I have admired forever.
And so you never know what it's
going to be like
when you meet those people.
She could not be nicer.
She could not be more genuine,
and generous
and she's a huge fan
of the show.
And so when they said
"Carol wants to know
if you want to go to dinner,"
I was so excited
that I -- and I went,
and I was shaking
and she started asking me about
Kim Wexler's scenes,
like, in detail.
She's a huge Kim Wexler fan
and then I burst into tears.
Like, she's just -- I mean,
it's Carol Burnett.
-Yeah.
-She's just --
I can't say enough
nice things about her,
and she walks around
with these little cards.
They're the cutest thing.
if you can find one on eBay,
get one.
They're -- it's a little
caricature
that was drawn of her,
I think by a famous artist
that her husband made,
that says "Carol's Cosmo,"
and it has the recipe
for the particular way
she likes her cosmo, 'cause when
she travels all the time
her husband wanted her to have
the comfort of the drink
that he usually makes
for her perfectly.
And, uh --
-That's so sweet.
-Yeah. She gives it to the
restaurant
when she gets there,
and it's amazing.
-'Cause she is -- the two things
I've heard about her,
is she's like, one of the nicest
people in the world,
but if you get her drink wrong,
she loses her [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
-No, exactly, no, she does.
I think it's, you know, it's --
-I think it also
must be so nice,
because I think that --
and I -- this speaks
to how intricately plotted
it is, and how --
how much work has gone
into "Better Call Saul" --
no one could fake
that they watch it.
Does that make sense?
-Oh, true. Yeah.
-Like, when she starts telling
you she likes the show,
and asking about it, like,
it must be so rewarding to know,
"Oh, this is definitely somebody
who's paying attention
to the show."
-She -- she does, yeah.
She does.
And like, wait until you see
what she does in the show.
Of course everybody knew that
she's tremendously talented
and an amazing actress, but I --
I had never seen her do
the breadth of work that you're
about to see.
-That's very exciting.
-It's amazing.
-That's a perfect
spoiler-free teaser.
You're very good at this.
-Thanks.
[ Laughter ]
-You, um --
-By the way, I have had somebody
fake that they've seen the show.
-Really?
-Yeah, drunk --
drunk guy at a party.
But, was like, going on and on
about how he much
he loved it, and then he asked
me who I play.
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "The blonde woman."
-Oh, no.
That's really bad.
Like, you didn't see --
have much of a plan at all.
-No, no plan.
-You filmed in Albuquerque,
and I did not realize
that you -- your roommates
over the course
of the last few seasons
were your co-stars Bob Odenkirk
and Patrick Fabian.
-Yes.
-So how did that start,
that you decided
all to live together?
-Well, we kept having to --
we all lived apart
and were in
different rentals there,
and constantly needed to
rehearse scenes,
we'd rehearse them ad nauseam,
and run the lines
and talk about the scenes.
And it's very hard with people
doing 14 hour days
and late nights trying
to meet up,
and then also
it's just very lonely.
And all of our spouses,
are friends, and partners
are friends, and families
are friends.
And eventually Bob said --
I think it was like
season three, he said,
"Do you and Patrick
want to get a house together?"
And I said no for that season,
because it was one of those
things where like when
you get out of college
and a friend -- like we were
really close friends.
-Yeah.
-You can ruin that
really fast by being roommates.
-Oh, absolutely. Yah.
-And I was like,
"Why ruin a good thing?"
So they lived together down
the street, and Patrick Fabian
put like rock posters
on their doors
and made it into this
really bad college house.
-[ Laughs ]
-But I just ended up spending
every -- every free -- all my
free time down there anyway,
so then the following year
I said yes, and so for three --
I guess three -- the last season
we lived together for a year,
because it took a year
to shoot 13 episodes.
But yeah, we're very close.
-And your friendship survives.
-It did.
Did you ever live with them?
I mean, you've known
Bob for ever.
-No, but I've never lived
with him.
I've almost lived
with no TV stars.
-You should try it.
Yeah.
No?
[ Laughter ]
-I have so much more to ask.
We'll be right back with more
from Rhea Seehorn, everybody.